this is a wacky story from last week
that I missed and I want to mention it
to you there is something called SFTs
okay it's a condition that is short for
severe fever with thrombocytopenia
syndrome okay which is transmitted by
exited or exotic not exotic but exited
or exotic I believe it's pronounced tics
and there's been an effort by the
government of Miyazaki in Japan to warn
people about this how its transmitted
how to prevent it and they had a press
conference recently that was meant to
warn people about the diseases that are
transmitted by ticks they decided to
bring in a live tick to the conference
and the tick was placed on a white piece
of paper together with another tick that
it died after sucking blood all of a
sudden the live tick is no longer on
that piece of paper total chaos breaks
out in the room everyone from
journalists to employees looking under
pieces of paper and under the desks for
this live tick that has escaped didn't
find it and the local government
released two types of insecticide across
the entire press room could no one have
predicted that this might happen I mean
why not put it in a little glass tube
with a stopper and I get that tics moved
slowly they're not exactly the Cheetahs
of the insect world or whatever but why
not just put it in a tin in a test tube
or something like that it's a very funny
story reminds me of that South Park
episode where the teacher is showing
everyone a case of marijuana oh yeah as
if - so they know you know what to look
for what to smell for I guess and one of
the students just takes it and that just
ensues chaos I mean it's like the same
thing in this could we say that if you
were to be bit by a tick that's the room
you would want to be in with all of the
tick experts or something I don't know I
I had a tick actually attached itself to
me a few years ago I went hiking and it
was really hot out in western
Massachusetts so I know when you go
hiking you're supposed to wear long
sleeves and long pants but I didn't
because it was really really hot at some
point a tick attached itself to me I
didn't notice it until I was home and
showering and I thought I had a little
piece of fuzz on my hip like right on my
pelvis and I just grabbed it and tried
to pull it off and of course my skin
stretched with it because the tick was
completely attached and I looked up what
to do you put some alcohol on it and
then with tweezers you grab the head I
was able to pull it off and it released
I didn't know how many hours it had been
on me it was a long weekend called the
doctor explained what happened they say
well listen really you usually need at
least 24 hours if not longer to transmit
Lyme disease even if the tick was a
carrier you've only went hiking a few
hours ago yeah probably fine but we
should probably give you two days of
this antibiotic just preventative ly and
I said oh you know what I'm pretty sure
that that antibiotic is on my list of
antibiotics that I actually am an
allergic to and because it was a long
weekend this was before it was as easy
to like look at my medical record I
guess the doctor said you know I don't
have any way of seeing whether this
antibiotic is on your list of medicine
allergies and by the time I can get in
and look on Tuesday it will have been
more than the 48 hour period during
which you would take antibiotics
prophylactically
so I ended up not taking the antibiotics
this was five years ago or so and by all
indications I did not contract Lyme
disease so that's my tick story well at
least they were smart enough to not pick
a tick that was carrying this disease
right I presume just one that would
normally carry that disease but not
exact you would assume that the live
tick they bring into the room is one
that they know is not carrying this
disease SFTs you hope so really knows
but totally chaotic scene very very
weird I'm thrilled that today's program
is supported by taga dab the hosting
specialists offering whatever type of
hosting package is good for your
business or project this includes
dedicated and virtual private server
solutions
cloud server options which are
increasingly popular as well as custom
server solutions taga dabs web hosting
services support a really broad range of
customers and businesses around the
world and this includes bloggers tech
startups
traders and finance gamers web
developers really whatever you can think
of and you can scale their clouds
servers up or down to meet the
particular needs of your business and to
also cut costs by only paying for what
you use
you can save twenty British pounds a
little over twenty US dollars on cloud
server options by going to signup tag
adapt comm /td PS and using the coupon
code TDPS 20 that's sign up ta ga da be
com /t DPS the discount code all one
word all lowercase T DPS 20 check it out